let's try to find the sum of this right
over the sum or let's try to evaluate
this expression right over here so we're
evaluating what this what this sum turns
out to be now there's a bunch of ways to
do this you could literally just do it
by brute force you could see well what
does this equal when n equals 1 when n
equals 2 all the way to n equals 7. and
that would be completely legitimate but
i view this as an opportunity to look at
some properties of sigma notation
so let's split this out so the first
thing that you might say is well look if
i were to sum up all of these if i were
to if i were when n equals 1 and then n
equals 2 all the way to n equals 7 it's
reasonable that this is going to be the
same thing as the sum of
the sum of three n squared
from n equals one to seven
plus
plus the sum
from n equals one to seven of two n
square of two n i should say that right
over there
plus
plus the sum
plus the sum from n equals 1 to 7 of 4.
and if this if you find this a little
bit confusing i encourage you to expand
both of these things out and realize
that when you rearrange the terms that
you will get these two things i'm not
doing a rigorous proof here but
hopefully if you were to expand this out
you would see that this is not an
unreasonable thing to claim right over
here
now out of all of these this last this
last piece is pretty easy to evaluate
when n equals one this thing is equal to
four when n equals two this thing is
equal to four when n equals three this
thing is equal to four so you're
essentially going to take four
you're going to take seven fours and add
them together so this is essentially
just going to evaluate to 7 times 4 or
28.
now let's look at this piece right over
here
now we once again we can just do it by
brute force 2 times 1 is 2 plus 2 times
2 is 4. so you're going to essentially
do the first 7 multiples of 2 is one way
that you could think about this or if
you if we were to expand it out actually
let me expand it out this is going to be
plus 4
plus 2 plus 4 plus 6 all the way
all the way to
when this is 7 all the way to 14. you
could factor out a 2 and so this is
going to become 2 times 1 plus 2
plus 3 all the way to 7 and so you can
rewrite this piece right over here as
the sum
as 2 times the sum so we're essentially
just factoring out the 2 2 times this
sum which is the sum from n equals 1 to
of n
so this is this piece
we still have this 28 that we have to
add
so we have this 28 and let me draw the
parentheses so you don't think that the
28 is part of this right over here
and now we can do the same thing with
this 3 times n we're taking from n
equals 1 to 7 of 3n squared doing the
same exact thing over as we just did in
magenta this is going to be this is
going to be equal to 3
times
the sum from n equals one to seven
of n squared
we're essentially factoring out the
three we're factoring out the two
n
squared and once again we could put
parentheses just to clarify things
now at this point there are formulas to
evaluate to evaluate each of these
things there's a formula to evaluate
this thing right over here there's a
formula to evaluate this thing over here
and you can look them up and actually
i'll i'll give you the formulas if in
case you're curious this formula one
expression of this formula is that this
would is going to be n
to the third over three plus n squared
over two
plus n
over six that's one formula for that
and one formula for this piece right
over here going from n equals one
to seven or sorry let me make it clear
this this n is actually what your
is what your terminal kind of value
should be so this should be seven to the
third power
over three so it's not this n i was just
mindlessly using the formula seven to
the third over three plus seven squared
over two plus seven
over 6. so that's this sum and this sum
you could view it as the average of the
first and the last term so the first
term is one the last term is seven so
take their average and then multiply it
times the number of terms you have
so times you have seven you have seven
terms
so what is this middle one going to
evaluate to
well one one times one and of course we
have this two out front this green is
just this part right over here so you
have two times this and over here you
have 3
you have 3 times this business right
over here
so if we evaluate this one 2 times let's
see 1 plus 7 is 8 divided by 2 is 4 4
times 2 is 8 times 7. it's 56. so that
becomes 56.
now this let's see this is actually well
we could evaluate this if we want and i
guess we could we could take out a
calculator if we wanted to figure out 7
third power actually let's just do that
just to save time here
so let's calculate
so we have 7
to the third power divided by 3 plus 7
squared
divided by 2
plus 7 divided by six
gives us a drum roll of one hundred and
forty
so this is going to be equal to
this is equal to
three times one hundred and forty let me
do it in that color
3 times
plus 56 plus 28
plus 28 and since we get our calculator
out let's just use it
so let's see 140 times 3 that's the 3
times 140 is 420 of course
plus
28. we deserve a drum roll now gets us
to
so this sum
this sum right over here is equal to
504 and once again multiple ways you can
do it but it's nice to know that there
are these there's these kind of ways to
break down the problem and there are
these formulas now i encourage you i
encourage you to look at the formulas to
see how you prove how this is actually
derived and proved i'm not a big fan of
just saying oh there's a formula for
this you just apply it you know the
formula here is is whatever this
terminal value is to the third power
over three plus that squared over two
plus that squared over plus that over
six i encourage you to look up on on our
on our on our side on khan academy the
formula for the sum of n squares and
i'll tell you where this is derived from
and also the the formula for the sum of
an arithmetic series and it'll and it'll
tell you where this is derived from